les numéro un soviétique et est-allemand
étaient à l'unisson pendant la clôture
du premier temps fort du 40e
anniversaire de la rda et pourtant les
5000 invités du palais de la république
ont d'abord entendu quelques nuances
entre les deux discours là ouais erich
honecker dénonce le charlatanisme et de
revendications revancharde de la rs par
mikhaïl gorbatchev lui reconnaissait ne
pas idéaliser l'ordre européen existant
néanmoins l'inspirateur du mouvement de
réforme à l'est a bien apporté son
soutien au régime le plus figée de
rampeau riant talent un soutien dont
erich honecker a bien besoin plus de
cent mille citoyens est-allemands ont
fui par tous les moyens son régime
depuis le début de l'année
quinze mille encore au cours de la seule
dernière semaine un exode qui a même été
favorisée par les alliés traditionnels
du pacte de varsovie la hongrie en tête
fait son arrivée michael gorbatchev
était accueillie avec chaleur par la
population est-allemande une arrivée qui
n'a pas été retransmise en direct par la
télévision officielle